okay let's finish this sentence
quantities that very directly go up
together and they go down together which
I take it is why they're called direct
variation they go in the same direction
okay we had a look last time in a m4
about linear direct variation so things
that rise or fall in a straight line
okay
now when we talk about all these
different kinds of functions we've met
well we had a list of five yesterday we
looked at linear and quadratic ones and
then all in one hit I add it on three
more do you remember what they were what
was the third one okay I've got a
parabola on the board already
it comes with quadratics okay so the
next one is the cubic I think I had the
hyperbola yes
there's no super Buehler there's just
the hi pepper and then last one was it's
the one that just grows and grows and
grows and faster faster faster
it's the exponential curve okay so let's
just quickly remember which ones which
so let's just give an example of each of
these for example that's really messy
I'm not going to state the general ones
because we looked at them last time an
example of a linear relationship might
be y equals 2x that'll give you a
straight line if you go ahead and draw
it a quadratic I'm deliberately going to
try and use as similar numbers as I can
a quadratic would be something like x
squared you see there's a power there
and the power is 2 as opposed up here
the power being 1 a cubic cubics an easy
one why cause X cubed would do it then
when you get to hyperbola you don't have
something that looks like this at all
you need a fraction of some kind right
so an example I gave you is like 1
over X that would be a hyperbola and
then lastly I can just squeeze it in and
exponential looks like these guys but
things have been terms have been
switched around so here would be an
exponential two to the power of X not X
to the power of two that's a quadratic
but two to the power of X that's an
exponential and while you're still
trying to gain a bit more familiarity
with these you can pop any of these into
some graphing software and lo and behold
the shape will appear okay so these are
all the different kinds of relationships
here and if these are the different
relationships through here in two
quantities we can say the two quantities
will directly vary in this particular
way so I'm going to introduce some new
notation for you okay given Y and X okay
my new notation R looks kind of like an
infinity sign with a bit missing off it
okay so I might say this okay so it's
like if I close the loop it of being
infinity sign but it's not uh yeah it is
kind of like a fish with a really long
tail so if Y and X are two quantities
and they can change their variables okay
what this means is Y varies directly in
relation to X they rise and fall
together there's another word we could
use here which is that I need some space
just under here Y is proportional to X
so these mean the same thing Y varies
directly with X or Y is proportional to
X because as you can see here see this
guy here y equals 2x if Y is some number
like say 10 then X is going to be half
of that would be 5 if Y was some other
number a hundred then X would still be
half of that it would be 50 so they are
in proportion to each other or in ratio
same idea okay but why might not G be
just proportional to X it could be
proportional to these kinds of things so
I could have this
this would mean why is not proportional
to X Y is proportional to the square of
X or Y is proportional correct that's
right so all this is saying is hey
there's a relationship here of direct
variation and the direct variation can
be linear or quadratic or cubic I can
keep on making different things here you
could even have this is what we haven't
drawn on here yet
but it is one that's possible you can
have Y being proportional to the square
root of x ok this would be the same
thing as saying it the other way round
that X is proportional to Y squared
these are the same thing here okay it's
just saying it from different
perspectives so this idea of
proportionality gives us a set of
equations okay and I can write an
equation for each of these okay I can
say for instance that Y would be equal
to some number K times X there's
proportionality there just like here up
here I could say Y is equal to some
amount of x squared or some amount of X
cubed or some amount of the square root
of x and K will be some number each time
which depends on whatever situation
we're looking at and we'll have a look
at some of the questions in 12c